just when you thought it was over Justin
Bieber strikes again hey guys welcome to
the daily Denny now I honestly did not
think there was going to be a third beat
to the Justin Bieber stuff but then he
had to go and run over a paparazzo last
night trouble has a way of finding this
guy and last night while leaving city
church service and Beverly Hills Bieber
accidentally struck a photographer
Beverly Hills Police confirmed e.t that
Justin was driving and added that he
stayed at the scene and fully cooperated
he is also not expected to face charges
but get this the victim 57 year old
Maurice Lamont Instagram from the
hospital just a few hours later hour
before my birthday hits I get ran over
by Justin Bieber it meant something he's
a good kid though I think the truck was
a little bit too big for him though
because there's no way he could see over
the front it was the slope it was on but
like I said he got out he was
compassionate he's a good kid accidents
happen I love that clearly he's doing
fine in fact maurice was released from
the hospital early this morning
we're told he only suffered minor
injuries meanwhile a source close to
Justin confirms what we already know
about him canceling his tour they say at
the end of the day he was sick and tired
of being on tour and he lost his
enthusiasm stress anxiety and trouble
sleeping were a factor and going from
city to city was not going to help so
you can't blame them there are you guys
coming up we have Cash's new video and
some exciting casting news for fans of
HBO's True detective but first you've
got to talk about the latest conspiracy
theory around Jay Z's album 444 do you
guys see this fans are speculating that
the name of the album is in reference to
Jay and his sister-in-law Solange's now
infamous elevator brawl you remember the
ones while Twitter users Stephen asila
pointed out that the address to the
rooftop bar of the New York City hotel
where the incident happened is wait for
it four four four
West 13th Street you hear me
444 the name of the record 13th Street
his fifteenth studio album he tweeted
I'm at the standard where Solange beat
jay-z's asked in the elevator the
address is 444 and I am shook and we all
are Steven especially because I was at
that bar when I was in New York City
last in fact we have a photo photo yes
and I obviously had no clue now this all
may be pure coincidence but you'll
remember when Jays album dropped I
shared with you one Kelly lyric from the
opening track quote you eggs to launch
on no one all along all you had to say
she was wrong hook now this is a case
for unsolved mysteries because I truly
believe we will never know what happened
on that fateful night but man do I love
connecting the dots I feel like a
detective
speaking of rehearsal Olli officially
signed up to lead true detective season
3 HBO announced the exciting news at the
Television Critics Association panel
Tuesday and good on them because my man
is on fire fresh off an Oscar win for
lewin light you'll remember the debut
season with Matthew McConaughey and
Woody Harrelson with a critical darling
season 2 was not but still network
president Casey boys told reporters they
are taking her time on this one and if
the first five scripts are terrific
either ways getting us fired up about
who they will cast as my personal is
partner but that's where I want to open
it up to you guys who should play
opposite rehearsal ax and season 3 of 2
detective now the sky's the limit so let
us know over on the community tab on our
channel and I'll share what you guys
came up with tomorrow and I'm telling
you right now that community tab will be
linked with polls throwback videos and
some fun behind-the-scenes stuff and
it'll be your chance to hit me with some
questions for the celebs I'm talking to
this is where you guys so take full
advantage all right finally have to
catch my breath because the Kesha
revival continues the singer drop
another music video so I wanna stop
talking i'ma let you guys watch this
is learn to let go
[Music]
yeah you know what that means those
streamers are back because she did it
again you guys whoo yes
Kesha she says learn to let go is more
than a song title it's become one of her
mantras over the last few years and this
is seemingly also in reference to the
dr. Luke drama
well while she's letting go she's also
bringing the fire so I cannot wait to
see what else she has in store when her
new album rainbow drops August 11th oh
man any excuse to bring these back on
guys that was way too much fun all right
that's it for us today as always hit
subscribe to e t--'s YouTube channel so
you don't miss an episode of the daily
Denny
and stick with ET online.com to see the
full catch a video I'll see you guys
tomorrow
I'm a streamer my way out of here bye